[Music]
hi
it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd and skin care
nerd
i talk about sunscreen a lot here but
sunscreen isn't the only way to protect
your skin
so today i'm going to be talking about
how to choose clothes to protect your
skin from uv
us australians were brought up with
these slogans if you were born in the
80s and 90s then you know the original
slip stop slap
this means slip on a shirt slop on the
spf 50 plus sunscreen
and slap on a hat if you're a young
whipper snapper who needs to get off my
lawn with your fortnite dancers
then you know the two extra ones which
are seek shade and
slide on some sunglasses so let's talk
about uv protective clothing
what's it all about and what clothes
should you be wearing
if you like this sort of nerdy video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and click
the notification bell so you don't miss
any videos
i think uv protective clothing is really
underrated in skincare
there are a lot of advantages to using
clothes as your protection against uv
rather than using sunscreen
firstly you don't need to reapply your
clothes you put them on and they're
going to stay there
you also can't well it's very difficult
to incorrectly apply your clothes
with sunscreen it's very easy you might
miss a spot you might apply too little
clothing is also by default broad
spectrum it protects against uva as well
as visible light
there are also a lot of disadvantages to
uv protective clothing
firstly obviously you can't cover
everything unless you radically change
your fashion so for most of us we can't
cover our face our ears
and generally our hands as well even if
you try to project your face with a hat
the problem is you still get that
diffuse uv even though you're not
getting direct uv that's coming straight
at you from the sun
uv bounces against other things and that
bounces onto your face
there's also the fact that summer is
really hot so the time where you're most
likely to get dangerous levels of uv
exposure is also the time where you
don't feel like wearing as many clothes
finding uv protective clothing is also
really tricky which is why i'm going to
break it down in this video
upf is ultraviolet protection factor and
it's the most reliable way to tell how
much uv protection you're getting from
clothes
upf for clothing is just like spf for
sunscreen if you're wearing a piece of
upf 50 clothing that means only 1 50th
of the sunburn causing
or erythema uv is going to reach your
skin just like with spf the higher the
upf number the more uv protection you're
getting
the difference is with spf and sunscreen
that only happens if you apply two
milligrams per square centimeter so if
you apply the same amount that they use
in spf testing
most people don't apply this much and
it's really hard to get this much evenly
all over your skin
with upf what you see on the label is
what you get when you put on your
clothing
although this can change over the
lifetime of your clothing which we'll
talk a bit about later the upf rating
for a piece of clothing is determined by
a standardized test
scientists measure how much uv passes
through the fabric
this is called transmittance and this is
done without using human skin so it's an
in vitro test
erythema or sunburn causing uv is a
mixture of uvb
and a little bit of uva light so what
scientists do is they measure the uva
and uvb
transmittance separately and then they
use maths to work out how much will get
through the clothing to burn your skin
in general you actually get higher
protection from your upf clothing than
what the upf rating is
that's because upf is sort of like a
worst case scenario where
all of the uv is coming straight on into
your clothing through the pores
in real life clothing is 3d so if the
light is coming in this way
only this bit is going to get that
straight on um
uv whereas on your other bits it doesn't
go straight through and so you get a lot
more protection
obviously the upf rating is just for the
skin covered so if you're wearing upf
clothing and your fingers are exposed
you're not going to get any protection
on your fingers
there are also regulations around what
sorts of clothing can get upf ratings
so generally it has to cover enough skin
so for example
singlets and bikinis generally aren't
allowed to have upf ratings
some places also have a limit on the
highest upf you can claim just like with
sunscreen in australia the highest upf
you can claim
is 50 plus just like with spf
[Music]
so with upf clothing you know what
protection you can expect
not many clothes actually have upf
ratings but regular clothing can also
protect your skin from uv
it just isn't measured and we know this
because
of course most of us have gotten tan
lines at some point from clothes
unfortunately a lot of fabrics don't
actually provide that much uv protection
so in one study they found that
one-third of the clothes they looked at
one-third of the summer clothes
were actually less than upf-15 less than
half of the clothes they looked at had
greater than upf 30.
it can be really hard to compare
different fabrics because there are so
many variables that will change how much
uv will go through
that's why upf rated clothing is so good
in my opinion
because you know for sure how much uv
protection you're getting
so i'm going to talk about some of the
different variables that you need to
look at
and generally what you want to do is
just tick off as many boxes as you can
the type of material that the fabric's
made from makes a huge difference
natural fibers in general just aren't
very uv absorbent so i'm talking about
things like cotton
rayon viscose and linen in one study all
of the white cotton rayon and linen that
they tested were below upf5
even if you have really tightly woven
heavy natural fabrics a lot of the time
the upf that you get
is less than 20. wool nylon and silk are
better
but the best one is polyester polyester
is really good at absorbing uvb
because of its structure it's got
benzene rings which is similar to some
sunscreens
when comparing similar fabrics made of
polyester and cotton so similar weave
similar thickness
they found that in general polyester had
three to four times the upf
of the cotton fabrics the big problem is
that polyester is awful to wear in
summer
so it gets very sweaty it's not
breathable it's just a bit gross
but you can get blends of polyester with
other materials and so this becomes a
lot more comfortable and more breathable
the uv protection does get a bit diluted
but it's just a lot more practical to
wear
so this happens with things like newer
generation sports clothes
with newer generation sports materials
you can get lots of little layers of
fabric
in the same fabric and so you get a lot
higher upf
so for example some professional soccer
shirts are greater than upf 100
fabric isn't solid and so uv gets
through little holes little pores in the
fabric
so if you have a fabric with smaller
holes or less holes you're going to get
a higher uv
protection regardless of what material
you're using so there are a whole bunch
of factors that affect how big and how
many holes you get
firstly there's the thickness of the
fibers with thicker fibers you end up
with
better uv protection there's also the
way that the yarn is spun
with more twisted yarn you end up with a
more compact fabric so again
higher uv protection then there's also
the construction of the fabric so
how that thread is turned into a fabric
knitter fabrics which have a little bit
of stretch to them
tend to be better than woven fabrics
with no stretch so these are used for
things like business shirts
then there's also washing some fabrics
shrink a bit in the wash
and the whole shrink as well this
happens a lot with cotton but it's
really variable
so in some studies they've actually
found that after 5-10 washes you get
double the upf
on the other hand after you've washed
your clothes a bit too much they start
losing threads and so they get thinner
and more threadbare
the threads get skinnier and the holes
get bigger in general
heavier and thicker fabric will give you
more protection because of the size of
the holes
and you can very roughly look through
the fabric and see how much light is
getting through the fabric
to see how big the holes are with really
thick denim you can get a upf of 1700
with a typical cotton summer t-shirt you
get a upf
of about five to nine with something
like 15 denier stockings you get a upf
of less than two
the color of your clothes also makes a
huge difference and this probably isn't
very surprising if you know what the
structure of a dye looks like
it looks a lot like a sunscreen with
lots of benzene rings
these benzene rings are actually how
dyes act as dyes
so the benzene rings let them absorb
some visible light which means they
reflect a different colour of visible
light and that's the color you see
but the fact that they absorb some
visible light also means that they can
absorb uv
light as well the denser the fabric the
greater this effect because
obviously the dye is sitting in the
threads if you have a bleach fabric
then you're actually destroying any
natural dyes that are in the fabric
and so the upf goes down if you have an
unbleached fabric the upf will be a bit
higher
but the best thing you can do is get a
really intensely dyed fabric
in one study dyeing cotton fabrics
actually made the upf go up three times
in another study dyeing the fabric blue
made it go up five times
and dyeing it yellow made it go up
double dyeing a blue was actually better
than using a special uv treatment on the
fabric
the problem is in most of these studies
doing the same color
made the upf go up different amounts the
most important thing seems to be the
intensity of the dye so how much dye
you're getting into the fabric
regardless of what color it is
in general darker colors worked better
in most studies so things like black and
blue
but in other studies other colors worked
really well as well
so for example things like red and even
beige again
as you wear a piece of clothing more
this can change because the dye starts
fading
and so again less dye means less
protection in general the types of
fabrics you're looking for are the types
of fabric that you use
in things like polo shirts t-shirts
sports shirts and dresses
in general business shirts are not very
good and this is because of the colors
they tend to come in
and the fact that they're woven and thin
polyester blends are especially good
especially if they come
in dark colors now on top of the type of
fabric you're using there are a few
other things that will change the upf
level
firstly there are uv treatments so it's
like putting sunscreen on your clothes
just like with sunscreen this comes in
both chemical and physical forms
this can happen during the production of
the fabric so for example if the
manufacturer decides to choose polyester
and make a polyester blend
they're adding some of that chemical
sunscreen from the polyester
you can also have physical sunscreen so
you can have embedded zinc
titanium and even nanodiamond there are
also treatments that you can add to your
clothes after you've bought them so the
most famous one is called rit sun guard
this contains a special sunscreening
agent called chinosob
fd and after one wash you end up with
upf-30 clothing which lasts through 20
washes
this one works best with natural fabrics
there's also
stretching of the fabric so if you think
about the size of the holes in your
fabric the more you stretch it the
bigger the holes get and so the lower
the upf
how much uv protection you lose from
stretching depends a lot on the type of
fabric so
the thickness of the fabric which way
you're stretching it but in general
you actually lose a lot of uv protection
with not very much stretch
so for example if you stretch a cotton
lycra blend by 15
you actually lose half of the upf
protection if you stretch your stocking
by thirty percent
the upf actually goes to one ninth and
this isn't very much so this is what it
looks like so generally for sun
protection
go for looser fitting clothing
especially if it's a stretchy material
with wet clothing you also tend to get
lower upf protection which you might
have already guessed if you've seen
a patch of clothing go see-through when
it's wet the problem is the uv
protection can also go
up when clothing's wet and it's pretty
much impossible to predict which way it
goes
in general cotton clothing tends to
decrease in uv protection when it's wet
so a dry t-shirt will be upf five to
nine
a wet t-shirt will be upf three to four
point five
but outside of that you pretty much
can't say either way
so if you're looking for uv protective
clothing what you want is
synthetic fabrics tightly woven fabrics
with tiny holes
you also want dark intense colors and
you want them to cover as much of your
body as possible
unfortunately what this also means is
that it's probably not going to be very
nice to wear if you're out in the sun
and very active so i think that's the
big advantage of upf rated clothing
you can get things like special
technologies within the fibers or added
to the fibers
and so you can find comfortable clothes
that will give you a guaranteed level of
uv protection
that means you can also cut down how
long it takes to reapply sunscreen
and you don't have to worry about
getting the sunscreen on hard to reach
places
[Music]
so here are some brands of upf clothing
i've actually tried
this is a hoodie from uniqlo's uv range
it's got really high uv protection so
upf 50 even though it's really light and
cool so they use some of their aerism
technology
so that it's really breezy on your skin
to get this really high protection
they've added special filters to the
fibers that block and reflect uv
the problem with uniqlo is that there's
only about four upf rated pieces of
clothing
and so it's really limited although it
comes in like every color
it's also really affordable so i think
this hoodie was about thirty dollars
so if i had to make one big complaint
about this is that the pocket size is
really weird it doesn't quite fit your
phone in comfortably
you can sort of squish it in there and
it gets really snug which i guess is
good because then you're less likely to
drop it
there are also thumb holes in the sleeve
which is a really common feature with
upf
rated clothing it means that it protects
the back of your hands a bit
the problem with this is that with most
of these it's not grippy
and this is actually the hoodie i was
wearing with
my thumb in the thumb hole when i
dropped my phone and cracked the screen
for the first time in one and a half
years so
i kind of hate this hoodie but it is
really protective
i also have this rash vest from mecha
cosmetica
rashfest when i think of rashvest i
think of these really uncool awful
designs from the
90s so they're like fluoro um they have
this little like weird neck
thing they have really awful patterns
and yeah pretty much the moment i turned
12 i was like right no more of this i'm
wearing cool swimmers
but in recent years there's been like a
whole bunch of really nice
looking rash vests that have come out i
don't know why they're called a rash
vest when they're not a vest at all
so usually they've got like at least
half like short sleeves
with this one and a lot of other ones
they actually have long sleeves
the rash bit is apparently i think if
you're a cool surfer person
um you don't get like what um surfboard
burn
on the front of your chest if you're
wearing one of these this is upf 50 and
it's made from like a stretchy nylon
elastane so rashfests are meant to be
worn while you're swimming and so you
don't have to worry as much about all
the sunscreen coming off in the water
you only have to reapply to a much more
limited area
and of course the worst thing is trying
to apply sunscreen to your back and of
course this covers your back
when i was talking about upf protective
clothing a lot of my followers suggested
solbari to me and i'm actually wearing a
solbari shirt now
this one so barry actually sent me a few
items of their clothing to look at
when i asked them about the technology
they used in their clothes
mecca also sent me the rashvest for a
different thing so the thing i really
like about solbari is that they have
really nice
fashionable designs that look like
normal clothes
some of their clothing is probably a bit
more like avant-garde
it really depends on what you're
comfortable wearing although now i think
maybe masks are a lot more acceptable
so we've sold barry's clothes as well as
the fabrics that they use that are
really high uv protection
they also have design aspects of their
clothes as well which help protect you
from the sun
so for example a lot of their clothes
have these thumb holes which means that
you can put them like this and that
protects the back of your hands
a lot of their clothes also fit really
tightly around your neck or
they can even go up above your neck and
so that gives you more neck protection
because that is a really common place to
get burnt
so barry have a bunch of different
fabrics with different technologies in
them
so some of them are more breathable some
of them are moisture wicking
some of them are cooling and there's
also ones which are anti-odor
there's a sensitive range which is
really good if you have sensitive skin
that's also sun sensitive
these are a blend of organic cotton and
bamboo and they have a really high upf
but they're also very good at cooling
and so you don't get that extra
irritation from heat
they don't use any chemical additives in
their fabrics and so that's really good
in case you have some sort of chemical
sensitivity
there's also the cooler sun fabric which
feels really cool
and so even if you have things like
really dark colors that absorb
uv really well you still don't get
really hot in the sun
i really like these sleeves so these are
sleeves with thumb holes in them
they go up to around your upper arm and
so you can put this on under any sort of
t-shirt to give your arms a bit of extra
protection which is also really good if
you drive
of course you can also wear driving
gloves there's another brand called
cooler bar which a lot of people
recommended
they have a sort of similar thing going
on where they have
fashionable normal looking clothes that
have really high uv protection
so i hope you like this video i'm quite
new to upf clothing so if you have any
extra tips leave them for me in the
comments
you can also like this video subscribe
to my channel you can follow me on
instagram and check out my blog for more
nerdy beauty science
see you next time to nerd out more